what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and also guys we
just dropped merch so I just made women
shouldn't vote t-shirts I I tweeted this
t-shirt it got 15 million views on
Twitter and a lot of really mad liberals
so if you want to go around town and
have women you know guys always talk
about picking up women right I'm helping
you guys out women will come up to you
all the time in the shirt
um so the link to that is in the
description it's at the audacity Network
dot store that's the audacity Network
dot store Okay so
today's topic so as you guys know I'm
always tweeting I'm like I'm like the
queen of Twitter I just tweet tweet
tweet tweet tweet tweet so yesterday I
was thinking
and I was thinking about how in society
how we can gather information from
listening to stories and hearing
patterns and so I was really curious
from the men what was the worst cheating
story that you've heard of so I had two
tweets I tweeted what is the worst
cheating story you heard of and what was
the red pill moment where you realized
women aren't as innocent as they seem
and I told my producers to pick out the
best of these stories all right so we
got Stephen Paul
I was with my wife and girlfriend for 20
years from 1980 married for 14. three
sons at the time we split were 10 8 and
3 years old a small two-bedroom home in
a nice neighborhood but was able to
expand to a nice five bedroom two-story
3 400 square foot home the problem was
the contractor my wife and I hired is
that they started dating while the house
was being built while I was at work
all the clues were there but I did not
see them until years later
hilarious Clues really I was not smart
enough to see them at the time it cost
me over 3 million in alimony and child
support and more in the corrupt family
court system
I'll never get married again
it's interesting because a lot of people
will demonize the men that walk away
from Marriage as just being guys that
can't get laid that women don't like
this man lost 3 million in the family
court system just imagine how much time
it took this guy to get that 3 million
and now he's losing it in the family
court system and guys for this to not be
a pattern is a little bit silly because
we have the old Trope of the pool boy
right and there's you know and there's a
reason in history
um they used to they used to castrate
slaves that worked for the guys because
they didn't want them screwing the wife
women have always been monkey branchers
we even just saw this with Tom Brady and
Gisele where right after the divorce
Giselle was seen with um their kids
karate instructor you know this is
definitely a pattern and a reason why uh
men you know quote unquote controlling
men keep their women away from certain
types of guys is because women have a
tendency to Monkey Branch AA USA 8 says
while at Sea during the Iranian hostage
crisis we had a large bulletin board
filled and overlapped by letter Sailors
had gotten from wives doing a divorce on
them mine came in a Christmas card
saying I want a divorce the bulletin
board was overfilled halfway through
deployment and the crew size was only
550. my card was added to the rest
coming home a large box was in front of
the kitchen sink overflowing with empty
bottles and beer canned cans that she
could not get rid of when I lifted it a
pair of her soiled panties were
underneath I thank the Sailor whoever he
was who left it there as a silent
confirming message
wow
this was during the Iranian hostage
crisis
these women are just divorcing their men
all right Mark Essence says GI Jane and
Will Smith is pretty cold interviewing
the guy so how did meet cuckolding you
make you feel and then her telling him
to slap Chris Rock publicly to protect
her honor and virtue that's
Shakespearean yeah guys this is what
happens when men are led by women women
just sort of lead to destruction I don't
know what it is about us I don't know
why we do this
but I I just don't see many
relationships that are female-led that
really lead to good things and you see
that with Will Smith and Jada you see
how the kids turned out when things are
out of order and they disrespect the
husband the men in the family grew up
being led by their emotions and the
women in the family grow up
disrespecting men it's a very common
Trope Felipe Pierre probably mine I've
been with her for four years and when we
started dating her son had just been
born I raised him as my own child she
asked her dentist out she came out with
him on a Thursday night and guess who
she used to take care of her child on
that day me
the audacity this is so crazy guys and
this is the thing this is modern
marriage
and you know I think you get a little
bit more honest responses on Reddit and
on Twitter and I know some stories
obviously are going to be made up but I
think the point is
this idea that marriage is just this
innocent thing where you can just find a
good woman and trust her
um is a little bit silly with the laws
being the way they are the media
pandering to us and other men lying to
us
um and this is the problem with
promiscuity
you know they say can you wife a hoe a
lot of hoes get married but the truth of
the matter is after about five partners
um and even at like three Partners
women's ability to stay happy married is
very low and they're going to be
consequences for men marrying hoes
all right
Godless heathrin says
why is that your username you guys have
the all right
just today I learned that a boss at my
job got caught cheating on camera
messing around with a female supervisor
while at work both were fired she was
pregnant at the time and had five other
kids and her husband worked there too
and everyone knows can you imagine that
guys imagine not only did you get
cheated on not only did people find out
you got cheated on
everyone you have to go to work
I would quit I would quit would you quit
King if that happened to you I would
quit
I would find a new job
and now I gotta work with the guy guy my
guy my wife cheated on
and my wife oh no I would quit I would
find a new job oh no couldn't be me if I
was a guy anyways
Elliot says when I was 13 years old my
brother was dating a girl who was about
24 years old she got me to go into her
room thinking she had to grab something
before we picked up my brother from work
and she seduced me into having sex with
her and my brother never forgave me for
it
oh that's so sad he's only 13.
and you know what's crazy I've heard
this story from so many guys either on
the show or just like guys that I know
where they lost their virginity from
like a babysitter it's really like
predatory women are absolutely real and
you see it all the time with like I
remember we had a teacher in high school
oh my gosh this woman would totally
flirt with all the guys it was so crazy
they would dress up like provocatively
at school and she was just like a ball
buster chick all right we have another
story I know a girl during uni who is
cheating on her boyfriend she would lie
to her boyfriend and tell him she was
going to study sometimes he would pick
her up and drop her off to study this is
five years ago they have four kids now
and the guy still has no idea
you know this reminds me I'll tell you
guys a cheating story I I've told the
story on the show so many times but you
know maybe you're new here when I was um
when I was at University or I'm at
College
um there was a girl on my team that was
with um
she was literally with
and I didn't know her super well but I
definitely saw her go into the bathroom
with like an ex-boyfriend of hers and
then her new boyfriend like showed up to
this place yeah and she ended up like I
think they're still together to this day
those were responses to my first tweet
my second tweet man what was your red
pill moment where you realized women
aren't as innocent as they seem Neely
when I found out my loving girlfriend
who called me at work every day at 6am I
worked overnight so she could go to
school to tell me how much she loved me
and appreciated me she was calling me
from the bedroom of the guy she was
cheating with I learned about it when he
sent her a letter to tell her off
because he found out she was sleeping
with someone else other than me and felt
cheated on that was the day I learned
there's no such thing as proof of love
and this is another thing that a lot of
women don't realize a lot of a lot of
players are made
they're not born that way I think guys
have a more idealistic sense of love
than women and I think of this because I
think of back to college in high school
when women had more of the leverage in
relationships and I didn't see women
behaving well with that leverage and I
think a lot of women string men on for
for years that they don't want to marry
have no intention of having a family
with and are just really looking for the
next best thing
another story August 2022 at 34 years
old this is from Julian sounds it all
began with the appearance of Andrew
Tate's YouTube reels which started
showing up one after another following
that I encountered Kevin Samuels The
Godfather
um Kevin Samuels astroately pointed out
that I exhibit characteristics commonly
associated with a male lesbian a simp a
beta a man with feminine traits through
the insights of individuals such as
Andrew Tate Kevin Samuels Pearl Rich
Cooper fresh and fit and Sarah Don Moore
among others I've gained a better
understanding of myself than what it
means to be a man I've also become more
aware of certain aspects to watch out
for in a woman that has previously
escaped by notice and that's why guys
the red pill is is so important
it is so important for men to share
their insights about women with other
men because
this time in history is so unprecedented
there I I don't there have been very few
times in history I if ever where women
have had this many sexual partners
and the idea that women cannot be
predatory with a system that backs them
up is is really silly we really need to
stop you know criticizing the red pill
because it does save lives and you know
there are men that have this idealistic
view of women and when it goes south you
know they they end up killing themselves
and a lot you see this a lot with like
younger guys and that's why this
information is so is so important of
older guys passing down wisdom to
younger guys and this used to happen
before women policed every space that
men were in you know men would go to the
bar or they would go to the gym or they
would go they would have these all male
spaces where they could bring in their
insights about women but the problem is
women have invaded every single male
space and men can no longer share their
insights so what do they do they go
online and then what happens online you
know
women come in and tell men how to talk
women come in and say and shame them for
having these conversations and these
generalities about women there's a
reason there's a reason fathers used to
keep their daughters away from the bad
boys because they love them even the
nice innocent daughter there's a reason
we have a million stories
um in the media of a nice girl you know
just trying to tame the bad guy
um I think Romeo and Juliet this guy got
her to kill herself in a day
you know Romeo and Juliet took took
place over the course of a day
I mean there's a reason that the dad was
like we got to stay away from this
um you know and you see that in in the
movies too it's like the the sweet nice
it's on Bonnie and Clyde Bonnie was like
this nice girl and then she met Clyde
um and there's a reason that I see this
trend of women on the show they'll date
entertainers and rappers and these quote
unquote you know more notoriously Bad
Boys in their 20s and I'm not saying
women don't learn and then choose
accordingly
but do we ever really know I want to say
we do and you know maybe some do but
guys we have to be able to give
generalities and talk about the rule
before we talk about the exception we
know there's exceptions but
you know I I really think as women we
should really promote honesty let's be
honest
um the reason I ask that they bring
these stories up is because I really do
think we need to start as women
understanding where the men are coming
from I think we cannot improve you know
a lot of times the Trad cons will come
in and say pearl what is your solution
um which is a bit disingenuous because
who am I to solve all the world's
problems but I gave them a couple one
men only marry virgins everyone else
doesn't deserve marriage they don't
deserve your commitment sorry not sorry
number two women shouldn't vote merch in
the bio go get it guys
um but number three is actually covering
these stories the stories that make
women look bad the stories that don't
get mainstream media attention and
letting men talk about their
observations about women so they can
adapt and act accordingly because
honestly men are very benevolent in
general man are very nice to women men
have always been meaner to other men
than to women and I think that's why the
red pill is such a hard time because so
many men have this gut reaction to just
like protect women
um at all costs and
you know when you give men power and
information they usually act in a
logical way and if they start abusing
that power other men will come in and
police them and so as women I really
think we gotta we gotta just let the men
talk let them do their crude jokes and
stop whining stop cabutting in and
saying that's not funny stop butting in
and telling men how to be men
and whining thank you